[Music]
three years ago on a whim
best-selling author Danny Shapiro
submitted her DNA to a genealogy website
many of us have done the same often with
fascinating results but what she
discovered rocked her world in her
latest memoir inheritance Shapiro
examines the essence of identity and
what happens when the stories were told
about our very origins turn out to be
fiction this is my father's whole
immediate family Danny Shapiro still has
her parents wedding album from 1957 I
love this picture I mean it's an unusual
expression on my mother's face through
five memoirs and five novels the
best-selling author has examined her
family's Orthodox Jewish history and her
own place in it this is my birth
announcement which ya in 2016 encouraged
by her husband Michael she submitted her
DNA to a genealogical website the
results come back and what do you see
the first thing that I see is that the
breakdown of my ethnicity is surprising
the ancestry.com analysis showed Shapiro
was only half Jewish she compared her
results with those of her half-sister
and that was the night that my life
changed and it showed that we were not
sisters we were not half sisters we were
not related so what do you think then I
think that ancestry.com has gotten it
wrong I made my husband go downstairs
and call him but I knew it meant if that
was the case that my father wasn't my
father
it is possible to live an entire life
even an examined life Shapiro writes in
inheritance and still not know the truth
of oneself I always wrote about family
secrets and so to discover at the age of
54 I was the family secret I was
searching for something and it wasn't
until that moment where the lights kind
of blinked on that I
that I had been the secret and that's
what I was searching for if you want to
keep a secret George Orwell wrote you
must also hide it from yourself when
Shapiro
re-examined her past she realized the
evidence had always been all around her
I was told every day of my life that I
didn't look Jewish for example every day
as a child she was the little blond
Jewish model who Kodak featured in a
Christmas ad I would be like yea raised
kosher went to yeshiva fluent in Hebrew
I was almost like militant about it the
other clue came from her mother who let
slip when Danny was 25 that she'd been
conceived at a fertility clinic in
Philadelphia and I said what was the
procedure and she said artificial
insemination she asked if a sperm donor
was involved she said absolutely not can
you imagine such a thing it would mean
that your father wouldn't have known
that his child was Jewish so you tucked
it wide closed the door yeah and it
didn't open again for decades until
ancestry.com gave her a different answer
when I started to come to the conclusion
that my parents had known what they were
doing there was such a sense of betrayal
that they kept my identity from me do
you understand why they did what they
did I had to go inside of what it must
have been like to be them in the early
1960s and there was so much shame
surrounding infertility especially
Malins infertility
the other thing you wrestle with
obviously in this circumstance is is my
father still my father I mean the irony
for me is that my mother who was my
biological parent is not someone that I
ever felt bonded to my father who it
turns out was not my biological parent
is someone with whom I have a profound
bond you find your biological father
from Markab Lee quickly 36 hours and the
time that I made the discovery about my
dad well until the moment that I was
looking at a YouTube video of my
biological father
Shapiro protects his privacy in
inheritance but reveals he was a 78 year
old retired doctor who'd been a sperm
donor was it easier for you to deal with
this because you could write about it
writing is how I process everything it's
kind of my church it's my it's my faith
it's my temple it's it's how I
understand the world inheritance is a
meditation on identity by a woman whose
own sense of self was shaken to the core
what did you learn about identity that
it comes from so many different places a
friend of mine early on said to me when
you get to the other side of this you
will be free do you feel free I do if
you're free what are you free of there
was always some kind of disconnect
within me something that I felt a little
haunted by that feels going that really
feels gone we create a mythology for
ourselves that we carry with us so when
were forced to rewrite it it's very
upsetting right but to understand it as
mythology is actually pretty liberating
one thing that made this difficult for
Danny was her parents were both long
deceased her biological father actually
went on become a medical ethicist but
even he said when he was a student and a
sperm donor he had never considered you
know that he might end up having kids
and this is the big question of this
book which is should children have the
right to know what their origins are Wow
this so resonates with me and you know
why yes you know why